[Music]
hello everyone
my name is miku gaechev i'm working on
angular
at google today david and i will share
with you how to build future proof
web applications with angular and
tensorflow.js google has been pioneering
in the machine learning space with
different products
for example with google assistant using
voice recognition
image recognition in google photos and
smart compose
in gmail to take advantage of machine
learning with javascript
we've been using tensorflow.js
tensorflow.js is an open source project
which allows anyone to run existing
ml models retrain them or develop custom
models
for more specific use cases one of the
strengths of tensorflow.js
is that it sets the foundation for many
successful libraries and tools
few popular examples are danfo.js
face api and many others using
tensorflow.js in the browser usually
involves
installing it or referencing it with
script tags
after that configuring it and finally
querying the model
you'll first have to start by installing
tensorflow.js
a model and the backend that will
execute
this model after that you can configure
the model and
integrate it with your existing
front-end text stack
for example with the framework that
you're using
finally you'd query the model
potentially multiple times
getting a stream of results
angular is a platform which comes with
batteries included
let us see how using the framework and
your cli
and rxjs we can make this process even
simpler
angular cli can automatically install
the packages
you need and integrate them with your
application
angular has a good integration with rxjs
which knows how to handle a stream of
results
and could help you query the model the
angular framework
offers an expressive optimizable
template syntax
which can hide all the complexity of
interacting with machine learning
and now let us look at an example
let's say that we're building a chat
application where we can send messages
to other users
when we type something into the chat box
the app gives us heads up if the message
could be considered
offensive by the people we're chatting
with to do this
when the user starts typing something
into the text box we need to check
if their message is toxic or not a naive
approach
would be to get the words in the
sentence and check if any of them
belongs to a dictionary of toxic words
this however can return some false
positives
for example calling a person horrible
is toxic but expressing our opinion that
the weather is horrible
will probably not hurt anyone's feeling
and should be considered
non-toxic this means that our basic
heuristic is not going to work
well in the general case luckily though
tensorflow.js
offers a toxicity model which by using
natural language processing categorizes
a sentence as
toxic based on different criteria
you can find this model in the node
package registry
to use it in our application we'll first
have to install it
after that we'll have to import it
together with tensorflow.js in the
application
next we'll have to configure the model
and load it
after that we'll have to add a change
event listener to the chat box
and finally we'll have to query the
model on each change of the input
updating the label manually if the
message is toxic or not
handling edge cases and race condition
would make this
cell the code even more complicated and
tangled
although tensorflow.js is fast and well
optimized
running the model on a large input could
also block
the main threat and cause frame drops
let us see how we can implement this
with angular
and its tensorflow.js bindings
all we need to do to install and
configure the app
is just run ng at ngx tfgs
this would automatically install all the
required modules and
integrate tensorflow.js with our
application following best practices
it will also export a pipe that allows
us to use the existing model and
query it outside of the main thread so
that we don't drop frames
and provide 60 frames per second
experience
now let us see how to implement the
entire app
by using angular first to show all the
messages
we would use the message list component
after that we'll provide an input
binding kit
to a text property this way when the
input changes
we update the value of the property
now we just need to categorize the text
as toxic or not
we'll start by showing the value of the
text property on the screen
we'll pipe it to the toxicity model and
right after that
unwrap the prediction by using the async
pipe
finally we'll just emojify the results
to give the user heads up
visually if they need to give their
message a second thought before sending
it
and here is the final result saying that
the weather is great is not considered
toxic but calling a person
horrible is toxic
there are many applications of machine
learning in web development
varying from natural language processing
image processing
recommender systems and so on and so
forth
in this example we looked at one sample
use case
now david will share a sample case study
on how we can
improve the performance and user
experience
in e-commerce by using predictive
prefetching
thanks minko now let's take a look
at the ecommerce site use case
e-commerce sites provide many
opportunities to leverage
ml to improve the user experience
we will make our example concrete by
using data from the google merchandise
store
in this case we're going to focus on how
we can use machine learning to drive
down user latency
latency is highly important to ecommerce
sites
because it has been directly linked to
user satisfaction
and can even increase the rate of
conversion
for example newegg shared that reducing
latency
through their prefetching solution
improved their conversions
by 50 percent by making transitions
four times as fast here is an example
of how a store would look without any
latency optimization
as you can see here whenever the user
clicks on a different page they suffer
an
irritating delay while the images load
this harms user interactivity and
prevents
users from having a smooth experience so
how do we prefetch the next page before
the user clicks on it
now this is inherently challenging
because every site has different usage
patterns
they have different layouts and varying
content as a result
it is non-trivial to predict the next
page that the user will visit
at the same time the devices that are
likely to benefit most
from pre-fetching are banned with
constraint and we have to be careful
not to overwhelm them by pre-fetching
too many pages
so the trivial solution of prefetching
the whole site
won't work we are going to address this
problem by creating a custom ml model
for every site that learns traffic
patterns to provide a tailored
high quality predictions this will be
trained on site data
from google analytics and will be run by
angular
to perform the steps will look as
follows
we will export google analytics data to
bigquery
which is a large scale data store we
will then use
dataflow our managed service for data
processing
to convert the data into features that
we wish to train on
next we will run tfx
which is our machine learning pipeline
to create a tfgs model
finally we will integrate the tfgs model
with angular
to make all of this happen we simply
configure google analytics to export a
bigquery
and use an ai notebook to work with
dataflow and tfx now
let's talk about how we can use dataflow
to obtain the features we wish to train
on
this code highlights how we obtain the
training features
for every user session using dataflow
we take as input a sorted list of google
analytics events
we traverse through the list of events
taking both the
index and the page path associated with
the current
event as input features we then take the
page path associated with the following
event
as the label please note that every site
is different
and any other features that would be
useful to the model
can be added simply by extending the
features dictionary
now there are other steps we need to
take in data flow
such as reading data from bigquery or
storing training data
but these should stay consistent across
pipelines and we've provided examples to
help you get started
tfx is our machine learning pipeline
that we're using
to take the training data obtained from
data flow
and train and evaluate machine learning
models in this case
we will use tfx to create a tfgs model
as you can see from the code here
to run tfx you will have to modify two
functions
the preprocessing function and the run
function the preprocessing function is
used to specify
the operations that you want to perform
on the data
before it is used by the model this can
include actions such as normalization
the run function is where you define and
train your tensorflow model
and convert it to tfjs we provide
examples how to use these functions
to create a tfgs model for prefetching
the next page
in addition tfx provides a rich set of
examples
for creating models for a wide range of
goals
now why use tfx there are many benefits
to using tfx
including end-to-end integration tfx can
directly
import data from bigquery cloud storage
or many other locations
it automatically inspects the training
data for abnormalities
that can harm model quality it then
trains the model at scale
using gpus and tpus if needed
finally it evaluates and validates the
models to ensure they are high quality
before they are made available to the
user tfx natively supports tfjs
which means that the exported tfjs
models
are ready to use with angular finally
tfjs is a general purpose pipeline it
allows you to
design your model architecture or use
one of the latest state-of-the-art
models
whether it be nlp or image processing or
many other domains
and these models can be deployed in many
places including servers
mobile devices or browsers now
why use tfjs tfgs works in any
javascript environment
whether it be browsers server side with
node.js
mobile devices or iot tfgs is optimized
for client-side inference it has small
bundle sizes that are lightweight and it
also supports model quantization
which can reduce model size by up to 4x
there's many benefits to client-side
inference it both preserves
user privacy and saves server cost
finally tfjs is fast it can use
client-side acceleration such as gpus
or web assembly to speed up inference
and it is specifically optimized
for a variety of devices including ios
and android
now let's talk about how we would
integrate our tfgs model with angular
our angular and tfx integration can
lazily load the model
to avoid impacting load time performance
which would harm the user experience
similarly it can run the model off the
main thread
as a worker thread to ensure the frames
are not dropped
negatively affecting the user finally
you can use the model to adaptively
prefetch pages
striking the right balance based on the
user's connection
our approach has many benefits we're
able to build
a custom machine learning model that is
tailored to every site
by leveraging existing automation that
connects
google analytics bigquery data flow
tfx and tfjs and angular
our approach is turnkey we can leverage
the services
and data that are readily available to
provide a high quality solution
finally this approach opens the door to
creating a personalized experience for
every user
we can use custom machine learning
models to provide
an experience that is tailored to every
user's individual needs
you can think of this predictive
experience as a progressive enhancement
over your existing ecommerce platform
thank you we hope that you will visit
the examples
to learn more
[Music]
you